last orders for a big mac and fries in
moscow
when the golden arches opened on this
spot in 1990 there were queues around
the block it was a symbol of glasnost or
opening up as the soviet union came to
an end my father and my mother was here
at the open uh
these first mcdonald's wow
what did they what did they tell you
about it
they tell that it was
very
crowded but the food but the food was
very amazing because it's something new
for them
now as sanctions close in on the russian
economy it's shutting its doors
mcdonnell says it wants to just pause
operations and that it'll keep paying
its 62 000 staff here but as most
foreign companies pack up and go one
member of the ruling party has warned
that the state should nationalize
foreign assets a retaliatory measure he
calls it in accordance with the laws of
war which by the way is a word that has
been banned in relation to what russia
is doing in ukraine
because if on state media what russia is
doing in ukraine is known only as a
special military operation what the west
is doing to russia putin calls an
economic war
fast food fast clothes apple iphones you
name it they'll be gone
the ruble down almost 40 percent this
year knocked further by the u.s and
british ban on russian oil imports
moscow's streets now packed with police
state-run radio sputnik today took over
the frequency of russia's last
independent radio station echo moscow
set up in 1990 just like mcdonald's echo
moscow was also an icon of the
post-soviet era
we visited last week its final day in
existence shut down for refusing to
comply with new legislation about what
you can and cannot say on air
sergey buntmann was its founding editor
we are
professional journalists
and we don't want to make propaganda or
anti-propaganda something like like this
but we want to to uh
to learn facts and to transmit facts or
opinions
he tells me his family came from cursing
the first ukrainian city to fall to
russian forces
and when i recognize all the streets
of her son now occupied by the russian
troops
i can remember
by my parents and grandparents
that christian it's a fifth or seventh
occupation of that
poor city of herzone for example
but the narrative told in russia is one
of liberation not occupation a military
operation to bring peace
[Music]
the last vestiges of independent russian
media have now left the airwaves
broadcasting as they did another symbol
from soviet times swan lake
always aired on soviet tv to buy time
when a seismic event was happening and
that's certainly the case now
dinah magnay sky news moscow